c'est ce mercredi soir aux alentours de
18h qu'un véhicule de police est entré
en collision avec un adolescent qui
circulait en motocross entré l' encour
et morpa plusutôt dans la soirée après
avoir reçu un signalement les policiers
du secteur ont tenté d'arrêter le motard
le jeune homme de 16 ans aurait alors
pris la fuite poursuivi par les forces
de l'ordre c'est à une intersection au
niveau de la résidence des nouveaux
horizons qu'il percutent un autre
véhicule de police présent par hasard
sur les lieux rapidement alerté par le
bruit des témoins ont filmé la scène ou
là et d'un coup on a entendu bah le le
bruit de d'une collision il semblerait
donc je suis allée voir sur par la
fenêtre et j'ai vu du coup la la voiture
la moto pardon qui était qui était
renversé avec plusieurs voitures de de
police autour les policiers qui étaient
sur place ont fait un massage cardiaque
j'ai appelé les pompiers du coup pour
savoir s'ils étaient au courant
puisqueau bout de 15 20 minutes il était
toujours pas sur place et ils sont
arrivés 5 minutes après réanimé sur
place il est ensuite transporté à
l'hôpital Beaujon de clichi dans les
haut de scèes en état de mort cérébrale
ce jeudi matin l'émotion était encore
vive pour cette mère de famille
habitante de ce quartier d'ordinaire
calme quand j'ai entendu les alors je
sais pas si c'est sa mère qui hurlait ou
sa sœur mais en tout cas moi ça me
déchire le cœur bien évidemment contacté
la ville n'a pour le moment pas souhaité
s'exprimer les deux policiers impliqués
ont été placés en garde à vue J j que
dans l'après-midi interrogé par l'IGPN
qui s'est saisi de l'affaire une unité
spécialisée dans les violences urbaines
devrait être déployée à hélencour et
morpa pour éviter des débordements